hum bons depois do do toque e eu não fiz
nada do que eu disse
portanto não treinar e não filmaria não
fiz nada e vou tentar que seja o mais
natural possível porque a realidade é
que eu venho aqui contar a minha
história pessoal com esperança de que
essa história pessoal ambos ajude a
mudar em um dia vocês mesmo a voz e vida
então primeiro ponto
não há ninguém nesta sala que não esteja
aqui para mudar o mundo
ok todos vocês vão mudar o mundo um dia
infelizmente mentária em questão
imprudentemente acreditam em você ou não
a sugestão durante toda a minha carreira
tive vanglória altivo na unilever antiga
mas chega um ponto em que já não
aguentava mais que o amava
verdadeiramente não sabia o que era e eu
vivia perdida não é numa sociedade onde
ganha 100 mil e 200 mil e 500 euros por
mês onde supostamente tem uma carreira
boa volta e significam afins também quer
também quero mas a realidade é que todos
os dias o sorriso era mais difícil não é
porque o final do dia eu sentia que não
estava a mudar a vida de ninguém
isso é uma coisa que eu sentir que vinha
cá com uma missão 110 mil da mas numa
grave e quando a sociedade num
instrumento do sistema aos nossos pais
nossos amigos as pessoas com quem a
gente convive no trabalho ninguém me
apoiava nisso ninguém acreditava nisso
ninguém achava que será possível em
ninguém achava que isso era um futuro
não é porque o final do dia o que
interessa é a linha que tu fazes não é
esse tostas a mudar a vida de alguém e
chama-se voluntariado e isso não muda o
mundo nem o dinheiro ao fim
o mês e este é o paradigma com que eu
sempre vi inevitavelmente do crash de
entendimento depois dos problemas que
têm na tua vida na infância não é um dos
que têm uma infância mais fácil é outro
tema infância mais difícil mas
independentemente disso quanto não estás
a ouvir o coração quanto não está a
seguir o teu caminho que acaba sempre
por ir numa opção atrás de outra atrás
do outro atrás da outra nem aí e vai
sobrevivendo interiormente sabe deus
como aos 31 anos tem 33 foi há dois anos
atrás de 2015 e da entrada na urgência
do hospital na urgência psiquiatria
direitinho ele tinha do trabalho era
controlador da financeira na altura acho
que estava no olympique do mês porque
queria se livrar do dia está a fechar o
mês
aí o que deve ter sido umas dez horas de
trabalho num gabinete é agarrado a um
computador agarrada à folha de excel e
no ambiente onde ninguém falava é o
tratamento roubou o tatran chá números a
fechar o sistema liga sul fama olha já
possam seguir a única o social que tinha
era na hora da moça ea atenção que agora
vamos ter bons amigos para ter uma hora
do almoço ou então antes tivesse a
coragem de ir almoçar sozinho acaba por
também de sentir um pouco sozinho e
então é era mais ou menos este dia e
este dia típico estava no novo emprego
há pouco tempo
fred estava há quatro meses um novo
emprego tinha acabado uma relação
também recentemente tanto tudo o que
estava ali na bolha aguentar aguenta a
aguentar foi parar na urgência
psiquiátrica como razão muito simples eu
tive uma insônia que durou três dias
porque não sabe o que isso é imagine o
que é que vocês querem dormir vão se
deitar e você negro como é o um descanso
começa a pensar naquilo que é mais
importante prêmio que eu não estou bem
como é que eu vou mudar a minha vida eo
meu cérebro entrava em luque depois
começava a contar as horas daqui a
poucas horas da manhã tem que levantar
tem que trabalhar aí não gosta do
trabalho
ai ai e branco e fica nisso althusser
dia e atenção o cérebro não desligava
nem 500 no-limit o que era uma das
sensações de desmaio em que eu escolhera
paga meia hora e depois logo se recorda
e continua a ser dia de festa passava eu
lembro me de virar uma opção a milha que
já tinha ido dormir na casa dela para
não sentir tão mal ele se olham também
interna que a minha cabeça já não não tá
eu eu eu sinto que eu acho que está na
minha cabeça não não estava em henoko
não me reconheço nestas palavras então
demos entrada no hospital
não eu já com grande filme a
esquizofrenia e florir a de que seja um
drama que doctor house e olha pronto
agora passar a vida toda em opções
também agora é limpinho vai ficar
internada com uma grande conquista para
a sociedade ver a sociedade estar nossos
amigos ou pseudo amigos da nossa família
e tudo é grande o ranking embora ea
rapariga do psiquiatra da urgência samu
diz a atenção vocês quando vão ao
hospital a urgência o número do cartão e
dizem olha psiquiatria imediatamente a
um desfasamento entre a pessoa que
estava pelado olhar pra vocês
parece me lembro muito sabem que os
únicos que ainda usam quando tem uma
pressão se vocês fizerem um cão com isso
o lado do campo não tem isso eu vai ter
medo de se aproximar como é que tu pega
ninguém gosta quando nós falamos em
depressão ou psiquiatria as suas e faz
tons para esse momento e espero também e
então podemos entrar na psiquiatria é
psiquiatra vir os crimes
não já não tá louca não não tem nenhum
sintoma assim em um sintoma de uma
doença psiquiátrica a não ser uma grande
em cima de opção e um esgotamento máxima
tudo e que o cérebro deixou de saber
desligar
portanto eis que pararem imediatamente
porque não é humano e o cérebro não
aguenta mais do que três dias saem sem
dormir
imediatamente ficamos coisa batman
imediatamente para explorar mais pra
casa e e faz tudo para dormir e eu
percebo lá vamos nós vale um xanax e e
enfim sempre que se vencer não desligava
a crescer com comunicação e primeira
esposa primeira pergunta já tomou alguma
vezes não é o que eu vou tomar aquelas
coisas grande ela não está mais no um
comprimidinho é o mais baixo de uma casa
lá fui pra casa
sábado domingo e agarrou e goiânia chefe
o confronto de emprego e foi olha agora
vou de baixa psiquiátrica que outro hop
baixa psiquiátrica
quanto tempo demora não sei fui baixa
psiquiátrica o drama todo que isso
envolve na época pelo mas estamos
completamente destruídos por dentro no
sentido em que não percebemos porque é
que não está a acontecer mais uma vez
fica naquela temos o que mudar o mundo
porque através do mundo está ruim e está
toda aquelas dúvidas que o diga em voz
alta que em épocas de só uma vez você
shopping em alguém que passa por isso
que eu queria compreender que nem aquele
instinto mundo dessa pessoa está
efetivamente a ruir
basicamente foi isso nos ajuda a dormir
durante os primeiros dias ainda corremos
sempre pode optar por que não há só um
sintoma não dormir ao registados ataques
de pânico as ansiedades a um tiro é um
dos sintomas que não é só uma insônia e
por mais que tenhamos um medicamento
para dormir depois falta o resto é então
foi uma semana quando durante umas
quatro ou cinco vezes
corri para o hospital amparo de
urgências até que finalmente um senhor
quando ele diz que naquela hora espera e
tinha duas duas voltas ao hospital de
fora e eu disse calma
então nesse eu vim com a medicação certa
por causa o que eu quero dizer com isto
quem toda a gente passa por isso
o primeiro ponto é a gente sempre ajuda
a conhecer que já não dá mais pra mim
foi meu cérebro que me obrigou a a mudar
mas eu sabia que eu não podia voltar
pois o sistema contava eu não queria
voltar ao emprego alinhava no lava eu ia
eu ia cair outra vez e quando eu já tive
finalmente a medicação certa de que a
medicação certa
malta é coisa mais baixa do mercado
é das coisas mais receitado por uma
psiquiatra e por um psicólogo claro mas
o que também aqui admite ficar o tabu de
que quanto mais uma de opção eu rival
temos que tomar e cinicamente é uma
coisa muito básica muito simples não é o
xanax nem é o vale tudo que nós estamos
habituados a ver na televisão e nas
telenovelas ou cai é uma coisa mínima
que nos ajuda em que ajuda o nosso
cérebro que é um músico como qualquer
outro
eu conseguir regular através dos seus
padrões normais
ok e quando no primeiro mês que
efetivamente difícil após o primeiro mês
em que o começo recuperar aos poucos
começa a ganhar força
de conseguir ir atrás daquilo que eu
queria uma coisa importante de dizer é
que foi tão fundo um mágico em que o
cérebro é um computador noé e o meu lado
racional frito literalmente chave do
deixei que eu queria vencer mas eu
deixei de conseguir conseguir ler eu
deixei consegui escrever eu deixei de
conseguir cantar e olha quanto outra
financeira tanto é que eu não consigo
contar
então o meu lado racional morreu não
conseguia fazer nada
em contrapartida o meu outro lado
criativo eu dei por mim a começar a
pintar paredes em casa pintar desenhos
mandá-las a desenhar e criar livre e
arthuro e foi cônsul a verdadeira
mudança da minha vida foi quando eu
manter mito ir atrás disso que o
instinto cria que era cantar dançar a
saltar a fazer o que quisesse e conforme
hoje pouco fui permitindo sem julgamento
de mim mesma e traz de que o chamava
cortando com toda a gente que está aí
com o país tem tudo tudo que era família
amigos facebook trabalho relações
antigas
eu sou motivo é a minha cadela e o meu
vôo da minha vida que é aquilo que eu
sentia que agora eu preciso de acreditar
em mim então eu vou tirar da minha vida
toda a gente que não acredita em mim
porque ninguém consegue levantar se e
vocês não conseguem é muito mais difícil
você acreditar em vocês mesmos estiverem
rodeados de pessoas que não acreditam em
vocês
o capitão o que mesmo que acredita em
tem dúvidas daquilo que vocês querem
fazer na vida e então você espera nem
coragem ea força de sua vantagem e
fazerem aquilo que o vosso coração disso
então após um mês de dubai renault a
descobrir um acampamento vip
então eu fui fazer aquilo que eu nunca
tinha feito na vida nem que era
literalmente viver e decide pegar no
carro sozinha tenda no no carro e lá fui
eu pode ser conhecido e que ela um mês é
viver na natureza e tomava em cascata
nua aprender a amar o meu corpo
a aprender sobre esses se eu quisesse
estar no à frente outra pessoa estava
porque eu queria não porque aprendi com
11 ao caixote do lixo
fiz com onzes o cachorro isto chama se
fazer reciclagem que quando acaba o
prazo de validade ea gente vai lá há
coisas que eu não consigo comer fruta do
cachorro não consigo mas aprendi a
segurar os limites dentro de mim é que o
que eu tinha tão conseguido pela
sociedade
eu aprendi a fazer com que eu preciso é
bom tem que seguir o instinto mas um ovo
não é uma coisa que me assuste buscar ao
caixote do lixo
tá se me protegi zuêra ou seja a limits
daquilo que a gente consegue fazer
dentro do que a gente acha que vai os
limites da nossa cabeça
já a acampar até até ou seja a pena
passa a ser a tua casa toca tambor era
tarde nas fugas aéreas até às 4 5 e 6 da
manhã e depois passar desse mês
a aenor estudo ninguém
a única pessoa que viria a morrer
claro que na altura não lhe contava o
que ela vai fazer nem precisava primeiro
que ter as respostas
pra mim mesma e às vezes em seu primeiro
passo e vocês têm que fazer com vocês
querem ponto e ninguém tem nada a ver
com isso
vocês fazem porque o ps não dizem sobre
isso porque você está em descobrir por
vocês e às vezes outras pessoas colocam
em cima de nós mesmos como acelerado são
deus não só os nossos portanto vocês
largam e vão fazer o que nos interessa e
por conversão mais tarde sobre isso não
é de estudo
o meu medo era bom a minha psiquiatra e
psicanalista e psicóloga deve ser nada
diz foi sempre vai existir vai levar a
indicação mas vai assim foi
ou seja am a minha volta me tiram ser
descobrir experimentar o que eu queria e
que o que eu era sem julgamento e depois
aos poucos durante cinco meses andaep
portugal fora é viajar da comunidade tem
comunidade ipioca comunidades
alternativas à unidade
um auto sustentáveis 80 mil
a moral da história quando voltei à
sociedade
sabia que tinha que fazer dinheiro para
sobreviver mas seria conectar ao mesmo
tempo livre a vida acaba por te ajudar a
perceber o que é que tu precisas de
fazer desde que tudo seja honesto
contigo ea realidade é que seis meses
depois de ter tido o jornal 'the teria
usado completamente o meu diaria eu
comecei a fazer o que seria hoje o meu
projecto humanitário e passado um ano do
jornal 'the seu imóvel fundamos o que é
hoje a nossa associação humanitária
onde já tivemos em crianças
centenas de uma centena de voluntários e
apesar de continuarmos a lutar contra o
julgamento da sociedade perante o facto
de que o humanitário não dá neri e
ednaldo não dá
a gente nunca tem em andamento
atualmente a taxa
a realidade é que não podia ser de outra
forma
por isso em sua vida
não deixem nunca vos digam que não podem
fazer seja o que for a e nunca vos
permitam nunca vos diga nunca aceita
inclusive um que vocês agarram todos os
corpos sejam mtur
ok importante saiu do frio
eu saio na frente e deixem-se
[Aplausos]